london has declared a major incident as
hospitals and emergency centers across
the capital
struggle to cope with coronavirus
admissions well i'm joined now by the
london mayor sadiq
khan a very good afternoon to you uh
just how bad is it in the capital
uh good afternoon the the virus is out
of control
the nhs is at risk of being overwhelmed
what i mean by that
is that we're at risk of the nhs at
hospitals
running out of beds over the course of
the next couple of weeks
if the virus continues to spread and
people continue to be
hospitalized you'll be aware that across
the country
on average one out of 50 people have
this virus
in london on average it's one out of 30
in parts of london it's one out of 20.
the ambulance service in london does an
amazing job on average
they would respond to 5 000 calls a day
on a busy day
they're responding to between eight
thousand and nine thousand
calls a day so we've already diverted
some of our fire fighters to drive
ambulances
and over the course of the next few days
police officers
will begin driving ambulances as well
londoners will have been
used to seeing major incidents being
announced during for example grenfell
and the london bridge
terror incident what resources does that
level of status bring to the capital we
know that we've got the nightingale
hospital on ice if you like with spare
capacity there
is that going to be enough or are
hospitals going to need
rapid action to help the capital cope
we have a situation in london where the
numbers of patients
in our hospitals with covid is 35
more now than it was during the peak
in spring yet the restrictions in london
are unless serious now than they were in
spring
so there's a number of things we've got
to do firstly
i'm calling on the prime minister and
i've written to boris johnson earlier
today
to stop for example collective acts of
collective acts of worship
in london which can still occur i
deliberately missed friday prayers today
but ferrari players are still taking
place uh churches good juarez temples
are still open
also it's really important that we
accelerate the run of the vaccine in
those parts of london where the virus is
spreading incredibly fast
we also need to make sure that we
provide additional
flash support to those londoners who
need to
self isolate we've got this ridiculous
situation
where londoners should be self isolating
because they're on a zero hours contract
that get sufficient support from the
government they're going out to work
because they need to work to get money
to be food on the table
and the roof over the head and
inadvertently either passing the virus
on
or cashing it so we need a number of
steps from the government to assist us
and me declaring a major incident i'm
hoping
makes it easier rather than harder
but secondly it's a message to londoners
you all need to understand
this is serious i've never been more
concerned
than i am now the best way we can help
our stressed
out strained and our stretched nhs staff
and our hospitals is by staying at home
unless you have a good reason to leave
and if you have to leave home please
wear a face mask
and just to give our viewers a sense of
how bad it is in the hospitals we
understand that the numbers of people
on ventilators has doubled since
christmas day
yeah i'm sorry to bombard you with
numbers but it's important to get across
the seriousness of things in our city so
we've seen a 30
increase in general and acute admissions
over the course of
the last week and we've seen a 47
increase
of those who require a bent event i
think about icus or high dependency
units the good news is that we've made
huge progress
uh since spring in relation to treating
covert patients
but with this new strain now we're
seeing younger londoners
being hospitalized and having to receive
ventilator
care what we can't do overnight is
invent
new doctors new nurses new health
workers new porters new cleaners new
engineers
it's the same number of staff working
incredibly hard and say this
i speak to nhs staff on a daily basis
often more than once a day
they're stressed they're strained
they're heroic many of them
are traumatized on what they're seeing
i've been told
it's like being in a theater of war and
that's why it's so important that we
understand
the simplest thing we can do the easiest
way to help those
amazing staff is by staying at home
unless we've got a good reason to leave
and if we do
we're a face mask as you mentioned we
are getting better at treating covert 19
the prime minister announcing those
two new uh medicines used traditionally
in arthritis as being absolutely
critical helping people
to survive it but that conversely
increases pressure on beds in hospitals
we're also seeing
hospitals incredibly reluctant to
release patients back into
care homes and it's all part of the
problem as well isn't it
i would have declared a major incident
if i wasn't concerned it's unusual
for a mayor to declare agents and across
a city but this is a pan-london
crisis what's unprecedented is the
duration of this
crisis the grenfell tower was awful
uh terrorist attacks in previous years
have been awful
but they've been relatively short
incidents compared to this awful
pandemic and what i think we're seeing
is a combination
of these additional pressures placed on
every single part of
our society in london whether it's
hospitals whether it's the ambulance
service whether it's the fire service
the police service
care homes or those who would normally
be going to work and
be contributing to our economy it's
really important we all understand this
is serious it's the most serious it's
been
and unless we reduce the virus spreading
the
nhs will run out of beds are people who
need hospital treatment in the capital
but not from covert
safe you raise a really important point
one of the lessons we've learned from
spring
is many non-covered patients he should
have received
a treatment from the nhs think of
serious cancer patients
or those with serious heart issues
didn't call
the hospitals or 999 or the nhs because
they thought
the sensible thing to do was to allow
others to receive the care or they were
scared
my message to those patients who need
urgent emergency care is please do ring
999
the nhs will treat you it's really
important we don't
make the same uh situation we don't have
a sensation we saw in spring
occur in now and so the nhs does have
headroom
to treat those patients who need
emergency care but for others
please go to the one one one website or
ring one one one or your gp
we need to make sure our hospitals are
treating those who need emergency care
we've seen another vaccine being
approved for use here in the uk today of
course
welcome news the big fear is that there
could be another mutation in fact it is
expected
by epidemiologists at some point in the
future of course we'll need to ensure
that our vaccines are able to protect us
from any variation lots of concerns
about this variant coming
from south africa the government
introducing these pre-departure
negative covered tests do you welcome
them or do you think that there should
be a test
on arrival we've got two major airports
here in the capital
you know beggar's belief that things i
was calling for in april
are only happening now and don't go far
enough what needs to happen
is what happens in other countries
who've been more effective at getting a
grip with this uh
pandemic yes a negative test before you
leave your country uh that you're
embarking from
but also introduction when you land in
our country that you don't have this
virus
and we to make sure that anybody who
does come to our country self-isolating
quarantine
for a period of time because it's
possible to catch the virus after the
negative test
from the country you're leaving
biggest belief that we're now at 10
months on
and we're bringing forward these
measures which don't go far enough
and it's really important our government
understands well actually
the health of individuals is linked with
the health
of our economy the longer it takes us to
get a grip with the
consequences of this uh pandemic the
longer it will take us to address the
economic consequences of the pandemic as
well
and it beggars belief that still without
in january 2021
nobody in government appreciates the way
these two things are inextricably linked
okay mr khan a final thought for you we
had our first
help for heroes clap last night clap for
heroes i should say
last night we're about to speak to an
intensive care doctor what would your
message be
to doctors up and down the country on
the front line treating people with
covert 19.
a more effective way to help the nhs
rather than clapping for care is to stay
home
i want to say to everyone who works in
the nhs uh i'm so grateful
we as a city are so grateful for what
you do you've gone above and beyond
uh we have nothing but admiration for
you i've been most of my family working
in the nhs they they've told me
about the strains the stresses that they
are under i'm afraid the bad news is we
need to continue to go
above and beyond for the foreseeable
future
i promise you i'll continue to try and
persuade londoners to support you
by staying at home and if they have to
leave home to wear a face mask
and my promise to you also is i'll
continue to lobby the government
to do right by you okay mayor sadiq khan
who's just declared that major incident
in london thanks very much indeed for
your time this afternoon